la stratégie zéro cowitz et mettre en
application ce qui aurait dû être fait
qui a été demandée depuis très longtemps
en fait un avoir 6 ans de la moitié de
l'année 2020 s'est testé isolés et non
pas à protéger c'est c'est donc c'était
s'était pas testé isolée c'était celle
ci est grasse et voilà et donc en fait
c'est le dernier point
effectivement c'est isoler isolé
réellement des gens pour casser cette
chaîne de transmission parce que
l'isolément n'a pas été fait finalement
audap a pris les moyens de
réquisitionner ce qui aurait pu être
réquisitionna bhl pour essayer d'avoir
une gestion des malades un peu plus
sensée dans le fait que les gens sont
rentrés chez eux on recommande aminés
des gens attendant d'être testé
justement d'avoir des résultats ou voilà
cette partie là n'a pas été fait
et finalement elle a permis de laisser
installer le fait qu'on pouvait essayer
de jouer la carte de la essayer de
contrôler avec une demi mesure dont on
voit à l'heure actuelle la limitation
que ça dunkerque ou dans les alpes
maritimes ou en moselle
il n'y a aucune raison de penser que ce
qui s'échappe dans ces endroits là ne va
pas s'échapper d'ailleurs et à mon avis
vu que c'est directement dépendant de la
qualité du virus laon n'avons que très
peu de chances d'échapper à de toute
façon de remettre une stratégie en route
autant la mettre de manière concertée et
intelligente entre et démocratiquement
pensé pour que personne ne soit laissé
de côté
voilà à mon avis à peu près pourquoi je
pense que la stratégie zéro co vite
pourrait être utile à tout le monde
[Musique]